in a time-lapse video it looks like a
monster coming alive for a moment it's
it's their innocuously then ripples move
across its surface it bulges outwards
bursting with weird boils it triples in
volume its color darkens ominously and
its surface hardens into an alien
topography of peaks and craters then the
kitchen timer dings your cookie is ready
what happened inside that oven
don't let the apron deceive you bakers
are mad scientists when you slide the
pan into the oven you're setting off a
series of chemical reactions that
transform one substance dough into
another cookies when the dough reaches
92 degrees Fahrenheit the butter inside
melts causing the dough to start
spreading out butter is an emulsion or
mixture of two substances that don't
want to stay together in this case water
and fat along with some dairy solids
that help hold them together as the
butter melts its trapped water is
released and as the cookie gets hotter
the water expands into steam it pushes
against the dough from the inside trying
to escape through the cookie walls like
Ridley Scott's chest bursting alien your
eggs may have been home to squirming
salmonella bacteria
an estimated a hundred and forty two
thousand Americans are infected this way
each year though Salmonella can live for
weeks outside a living body and even
survive freezing 136 degrees is too hot
for them when your dough reaches that
temperature they die off you'll live to
test your fate with the bite of raw
dough you sneak from your next batch at
a hundred and forty four degrees
changes begin in the proteins which come
mostly from the eggs in your dough eggs
are composed of dozens of different
kinds of proteins each sensitive to a
different temperature in an egg fresh
from the hen these proteins look like
coiled up balls of string when they're
exposed to heat energy the protein
strings unfold and get tangled up with
their neighbors this linked structure
makes the runny egg nearly solid giving
substance too squishy dough water boils
away at 212 degrees so like mud baking
in the Sun your cookie gets dried out
and its
and cracks spread across its surface the
steam that was bubbling inside
evaporates leaving behind Airy pockets
that make the cookie light and flaky
helping this along is your leavening
agent sodium bicarbonate or baking soda
the sodium bicarbonate reacts with acids
in the dough to create carbon dioxide
gas which makes Airy pockets in your
cookie now it's nearly ready for a
refreshing dunk in a cool glass of milk
one of Sciences tastiest reactions
occurs at 310 degrees this is the
temperature for my yard reactions my
yard reactions result when proteins and
sugars break down and rearrange
themselves forming ring-like structures
which reflect light in a way that gives
foods like Thanksgiving turkey and
hamburgers
their distinctive rich brown color as
this reaction occurs it produces a range
of flavor and aroma compounds which also
react with each other forming even more
complex tastes and smells
carmelization is the last reaction to
take place inside your cookie
carmelization is what happens when sugar
molecules break down under high heat
forming the sweet nutty and slightly
bitter flavor compounds that define well
caramel and in fact if your recipe calls
for a 350 degree oven it'll never happen
since carmelization starts at 356
degrees if your ideal cookie is barely
browned like a northeastern Iran a beach
vacation you could have set your oven to
300 and
to have a nice tan crank up the heat
carmelization continues up to 390
degrees and here's another trick you
don't need that kitchen timer your nose
is a sensitive scientific instrument
when you smell the nutty toasty aromas
of the my yard reaction and
caramelization your cookies are ready
grab your glass of milk put your feet up
and reflect that science can be pretty
sweet
you